the good news is this administration has
a ready explanation for why prices are
raging out of control and no it's not
their own crappy monetary policy no it's
not their own bad coveted regulations no
it's not their lockdown ideas or the
supply chain shortages that they have
helped film it it's none of those things
it turns out it's greed oh you see when
the prices go up it's greed so when your
meat costs more at the market it's
because the people who slaughter the
cows suddenly got greedy like a year ago
they weren't greedy they were real
altruistic then when the prices were
super low
prices are just a reflection of greed
okay this particular view of economics
is so benighted and bewilderingly stupid
as to boggle the mind
prices are not a reflection of people's
greed greed is a constant in human
nature
in fact self-interest is a confident is
a constant in human nature and
self-interest can only be served by
providing a product at a price people
are willing to pay if it were just about
greed then meat producers could be
charging one million dollars a pound
because after all they're greedy for
lots of money right but if the idea is
that meat producers are randomly raising
their prices out of greed not reflecting
underlying market conditions like labor
shortages and supply chain bottlenecks
and the inflationary economy created by
this administration
you're out of your mind and greed alone
cannot explain price increases because
again it is a constant in human nature
but here's gensake trying to again the
real reason meat prices are going up is
because of this administration's garbage
policies but here's jen saki saying that
it's really because of greed it's greed
it's greed
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates that is an area where
people go to the grocery store and
they're trying to buy a pound of meat
two pounds of meat 10 pounds of meat
it is the prices are higher that is in
his view uh and the view of our
secretary of agriculture because of you
could call it corporate greed short you
could call it uh jacking up prices uh uh
during a pandemic it was greed it's
price gouging okay now even price
gouging the way the government usually
defines it is not price gouging usually
price gouging means that a gas station
is running out of gas and so they have
to price the gas so as to ensure that
people still get gas okay when you keep
the price low it artificially stimulates
demand that is what happens with price
and supply curves
okay but but again
the the democrats always have a ready
explanation for why things are going bad
and it's because people are agreed they
did this with obamacare too right you'd
see companies that would increase their
prices to compensate for the fact that
they now had to pay for obamacare and
then they'd put that on their bills
and you remember the obama
administration the media being like how
dare they that just demonstrates how
greedy they are no it demonstrates that
when you artificially boost the prices
of things people have to boost the
prices that they charge to the downline
consumer
there's a weird pattern i've noticed
that crops up when it comes to the
understanding of price in the democratic
mindset
that that weird coincidence is that
every major industry that is private is
bad but every policy democrats push is
somehow altruistic and good
so for example it's not just meat
consumers i mean it's not just meat
producers it is also the oil companies
remember when oil spiked shen saki this
is just a couple of weeks ago gensake
suggested that the reason that the oil
prices were spiking was not because of
their crappy policy it was because of um
the oil executives and their greed too
it's always greed when it's when it's
people that the administration doesn't
like
the price at the pump usually moves
alongside the price of refined gas but
recently as you noted uh there's been a
split where the price of refined gas is
going uh down but prices at the pump are
going up that's exactly why the
president sent the letter to the ftc
last week because that's not what we
should see as the trend there shouldn't
be price gouging across the country you
shouldn't have oil ceos bragging out
there about the profits that they
benefit from when when prices are high
at the gas pump okay so it's all about
the greed of the oil executives however
when it comes to labor
and the price of labor right which is a
commodity labor is a commodity and the
wages are going up which means that
you're going to drive prices up as well
when the price of labor goes up that is
not because of the greed of people who
are attempting to get back in the labor
market of course then it's still the
great of employers it's still the people
who hire it's because those stupid
employers are so greedy that they won't
hire people at p at wages that that
people don't want to don't actually want
to take and so the wages are going up so
in other words the people who create who
demand a particular price for their
goods and services are bad except if
they're good here's jin saki explaining
we know we've seen labor shortages in
some industries in some industries
that's because they need to have a more
competitive package to offer to workers
it's a workers market right now we know
that people are looking for more
dependable benefits they're looking for
uh wages that are higher and that's
something that is incumbent on a lot of
industries to meet the moment on okay
the reason this administration is
failing on economics is because they
have a perspective that is not in
consonance with reality
it's heads i win tails you lose if the
price of oil is too high it's because
the producers are really bad if the
price of labor is too high it's because
the laborers are really good and the
employers are really bad no matter what
the producers are really bad always the
companies and corporations are really
bad and the government's really good
they're really wonderful and if we have
to blow out the national debt in order
to promote this idiotic idea well
nobody's really worried about the
national debt here is jen saki saying
that the national debt is just a lie no
one actually cares about the national
debt here's the thing about the national
debt no one cares about the national
debt until it bites them directly in the
ass the national debt is all fun and
games until it turns out that servicing
the national debt is eating up a
substantial chunk of your budget every
single year and you have to use
austerity measures like they've had to
use in europe in order to get your
budget back into realignment because
there ain't no one left to pay the bills
and no one's buying the bonds anymore
because there's no promise they'll get
paid back but here's jen saki pretending
the national debt doesn't matter because
of course she's a devotee as this entire
administration of the idiotic modern
monetary theory which suggests you can
just pump money into the economy at
record rates and nothing will happen
what do you say to people who say we're
just going to be having the same
conversation a little bit over a year
from now
i'm not sure what american person is
saying that or is concerned about the
debt limit but maybe there's somebody
you've met on the street i don't know
but i will say that um you know our view
the president's view is that this has
been done in a bipartisan way the
american people shouldn't be worried
about whether or not elected officials
are doing what they should do and
raising the debt limit to make sure
we're covering bills that have already
been incurred no nobody's nobody's
worried about the debt limit nobody's
worried about the national debt uh okay
so they're not worried about inflation
and if they are it's because they're
dumb
and they're not worried about the
national debt and if they are it's
because they're numb
in fact it turns out that everybody's
unhappy with this administration is just
wrong
how convenient if you're a democrat and
then when you point this out to them and
well well january 6th well well well
january 6 meanwhile by the way in in all
the major cities that are governed by by
blue
government members
the economy is stagnating
new york city job growth is completely
falling apart matthew hogg and patrick
mcgeehan reporting for the new york
times since the start of the year nearly
6 million jobs have been added in the
united states the unemployment rate has
plummeted to 4.2 percent close to where
it stood before the pandemic but in new
york city the economy appears to be in a
rut after getting 350 000 jobs in the
last months of 2020 employment has
slowed considerably this year with just
187 000 jobs added since march the
city's unemployment rate is 9.4 percent
9.4 percent that's more than double the
national average its decline in recent
months was largely caused by people
dropping out of the labor force
as the city plunged into its worst
financial crisis since the great
depression the unemployment rate
skyrocketed in june 2020 it was 20
percent now it's down to about 10
percent but new york has added back a
little more than half the jobs it lost
according to the state labor department
far less than the rest of the country
the protracted pandemic has shut out
tourists scared off the crush of
suburbanites who filled office towers
every weekday
just eight percent of office workers
were back at work five days a week in
early november
okay so they're wrecking their own
economy
and then the idea is that what you're
supposed to ignore that because donald
trump's a bad man who does bad things
who's bad
same thing is happening in illinois by
the way according to the wall street
journal
illinois is losing young people while
florida is gaining them there's a shock
state development specialist zack
kennedy notes the us population actually
grew in the prime working age young
adult age cohorts 25 to 29 30 to 34 35
to 35-39 illinois was among the few
states to see a decline in those age
cohorts
one reason is many students who leave
the state for college don't come back
only new jersey lost more college-aged
individuals out of state who never
returned
one of the reasons for that is because
illinois has
huge taxes
illinois new jersey have some of the
highest residential property tax rates
in the nation
the state is losing children its under
18 population has declined by 350 000
over the last decade
lousy schools are driving away young
families
each illinois household is on average on
the hook for a hundred and ten thousand
dollars in government worker retirement
debt
a hundred and ten thousand dollars for
each illinois household in terms of
state debt burden
this is what happens when you're in a
state like garbage
so there's been the good news is that
again it's all misdirection you notice
that it's almost direction right when
they fail it's about january 6th or or
in california it's about making a
californian abortion sanctuary state to
deflect attention from the fact that the
governance there is absolutely terrible
or that they're doing a full-on mask
mandate indoors again in california
based on
mcron in new york they're attempting to
misdirect by suggesting that they go
after lawmakers i mean after after gun
makers new york attorney general leticia
james she said she was on the view
explaining that that new york state was
going to lead the nation and going after
gun makers yeah that's going to fix your
economy let's show it sounds great
gun manufacturers and gun distributors
in this country are immunized no
liability whatsoever they're the only
industry that is protected in this
country and given the carnage and given
the fact that this is the ninth
anniversary of sandy hook i am sick and
tired of prayers and individuals whose
hearts go out to all of those who have
lost lives we can do something about it
and what we need to do is hold these gun
manufacturers and these gun distributors
[Applause]
okay but all of that is just a
distraction and you can woo that up as
much as you want view audience when
democrats are losing because they are
disconnected from the everyday reality
of most americans
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang